[Musique]
ils sont étudiants ingénieurs et
informaticiens
la plupart n'ont jamais touché à un
pistolet de leur vie
inspiré par la résistance ukrainienne
alarmé par la menace constante
d'invasion chinoise
ils ont choisi de passer leur samedi à
apprendre les rudiments du maniement
d'armes
ueli juan un ingénieur le fait pour lui
même mais surtout pour sa famille
dans un sondage effectué au mois de mai
plus de 60% des taiwanais disait être
prêts à prendre les armes pour défendre
lille contre la chine
ne veut pas avoir à le faire mais elle
n'hésitera pas si c'est nécessaire
secours de base la rend déjà plus
confiante en ses capacités
des cours plus poussée de guérilla
urbaine sont même offert janeiro la
chine compte dix fois plus de soldats
que taïwan est quatre fois plus d'avions
de chasse mais pour beaucoup de
taïwanais de la guerre en ukraine prouve
qu'il pourrait résister eux aussi
les élèves tentent d'appliquer les
leçons apprises de la résistance
ukrainienne s'est ouverte en sort de ses
gonds la meilleure défense c'est
l'attaqué
dix-sept employés en marketing qu'on
appelle profit est lors de cette
formation pour se protéger il faut
freiner et anéantir l'ennemi ajoutent
ils les taiwanais se bousculent pour
l'accès aux formations de maniement
d'armes de toutes sortes sont
les inscriptions ont quadruples et
depuis le début de la guerre en ukraine
qui exacerbe le sentiment de crise
taiwan la formation pour les premiers
soins en temps de guerre et tous très
prisé des ateliers comme celui ci ont
lieu chaque fin de semaine
dans ses cours pratique de quelques
heures offertes chaque samedi cet été
les participants apprennent à arrêter un
saignement abondant
on leur enseigne aussi quelques
techniques d'évacuation rapide des
blessés
[Musique]
la chaîne nous attaquent il y aura
beaucoup de blessés croit zhao je veux
pouvoir faire ma part je me sens un peu
plus braves après secours ajoute t-elle
innpu est à l'origine de ces formations
populaire selon lui ça témoigne de la
solidarité des taiwanais et de leur
désir de protéger leur démocratie et
la menace d'invasion chinoise fait
partie du quotidien à taiwan depuis
longtemps les craintes et inquiétudes
sont omniprésentes
et un bac
encore maintenant même si les tensions
avec la chine sont vives ou lé roi ne
croit pas à une attaque imminente
mais elle viendra dit-il dans un an dans
cinq ans peu importe comme tant de
taiwanais il jure qu'il sera prêt